joining us now with reaction he's the
ranking Intelligence Committee Chairman
Devon Nunez is with us your reaction all
this and I say because it's so
illegitimate so unfair and so
unconstitutional Republicans should not
play a part in this in my opinion your
thoughts well I think you you nailed it
on the head Sean that we have to have at
least one member of Congress and at
least one lawyer there to take notes so
we know what they're saying because
they're good if not they do control the
gavels they have the power and they can
do a lot of really bad things now look I
find it interesting that Pelosi is not
even going to bother to try to fight the
administration and take this to court
I think that's new information I'm
surprised at that but that means they
really are just racing to get this done
and finally I think what you're seeing
is they're on a sugar high with polls
right now they've got ninety percent of
the media poisoning people they've got
all the tech companies poisoning people
so they read the polls right now and
they want to race quickly as long as
it's 50 percent plus one to impeach the
president it's like I think you said a
rocket docket impeachment that's what
they're trying to go for okay now I want
to ask you specifically about Ukraine
we've all read the transcript there's
nothing there there's not even a need
for a non whistleblower whistleblower
but let's I want to get your reaction
but we do have Biden on tape bragging
about leveraging in a shakedown a
billion dollars of taxpayer money to
force Ukraine to fire the a Ukrainian
prosecutor in six hours and he signed an
affidavit saying that's why he got fired
or he's not giving him the money okay
that sounds like something really
serious to me
yeah so and that's why I believe if John
Solomon's reporting is correct from
yesterday that they've actually that the
Ukrainians had actually reopened this
investigation long before Trump had ever
even talked to the new Ukrainian
president so that could be ongoing if
you look at all the happenings in
Ukraine over the last few years it's
very concerning I hope they're supposed
to bring in the Ambassador the former
ambassador Ukraine from the United
States she's supposed to come in on
Friday I don't know if she's going to
come in or not but we were kind of
looking forward to having her in because
as you probably know Shaun Pete sessions
former chairman of the Rules Committee
he sent a letter about her about
concerns about that she was not serving
the Trump administration well in Ukraine
well of course she was removed we've
seen we've seen lots of bragging in the
press about how she's going to be the
one that really brings down the
president well I have questions because
my sources are telling me that the
former US ambassador to Ukraine
Jovanovic my little birdies whispering
to me I don't know if it's true or not
yet but I'm looking do you know of any
evidence that she may have used
government resources to monitor
communications of American citizens and
you know of any of these citizens might
have been journalists well what I can
tell you is is that we know what what
Pete sessions congressman from Texas now
retired we know what he had to say we
know that there are people within that
were that were not only Ukrainians but
also Americans that worked at the State
Department who have raised concerns
about this ambassador that's why she was
ultimately removed we also have concerns
that possibly they were monitoring press
from different journalists and others
that we don't know but you know we have
people who are giving us this
information and we're gonna ask these
questions to the State Department and
hopefully they'll get the answers before
she comes in on Friday but we will give
her an opportunity to shows up okay
because now what you're saying is very
alarming to me I have three people now
that have told me that they believe
there
is evidence that shows government
resources were used to monitor
communications in one case a journalist
that is a regular on this program with
the name John Solomon have you heard
that congressman well what I've heard
and I want to be clear there's that I
think there's a there's a difference
what I've heard is that there were
strange requests irregular requests to
monitor not just one journalist but
multiple journalists now perhaps that
was okay perhaps there was some reason
for that that it can be explained away
but that's what we that's what we know
and that's what we're going to be
looking into all right congressman Devin
Nunez as always thank you voice of
reason and courage in the house we
appreciate it